hello I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
remember how he did those reviews of
late 80s Early 90s commercials you know
the ones I said sort of existed in their
own cheesy little world well what if
there existed an entire movie like that
yes indeed I bet you anything it would
be called airborne I mean it this whole
movie is like a huge commercial for
itself aside from being another movie
Seth Green and Jack Black won't put on a
resume
airborne is a film I can only describe
as extreme generic miss then I say
extreme I mean actually because in the
90s everything was a dream and this film
is no exception this film has extremely
lame characters extremely bad storylines
and extremely embarrassing 90s cliches
so does that make it incredibly stupid
that's timeline let's take a look so
don't believe me when I say this movie
is just one big 90s commercial check out
this opening the waves of winter mother
nature has cast her spell
serious very okay you can't exactly
figure out what they're trying to
advertise but it's definitely
advertising something where does this
take place anyway ah palm trees and smug
Cathar into so low sports that require
no teamwork so they can show the fuck
off this must be California all right
then we're in an ad for California let's
try it let's throw our tool in at the
end and see what happens people think
like me California's all funny games but
it's really serious business we have
board meetings board meetings lots of
board meetings we run with the big dogs
everything's a huge production so if
California seems like your kind of work
we've got one question when can you
start
start your TripIt visit California
Dakota UK it worked it totally works so
this is Mitchell and a teenage boy who
likes rollerblading and surfing and
apparently stealing things seeing how he
went down to the beach without surfboard
and is now leaving with one fucking
thief how are the waves breaking today
Mitchell all right what is it who died
look at this kid it's like he was
constructed from every Disney Prince
that ever existed he even has the same
attitude listen the National Zoological
Institute has asked us to study the
Australian wombat that's great news I
mean we've never been to Australia
before summers that never-quit and
golden tan Sheila's I am Prince Ali
Ababwa just let her meet me we would
love for you to go with us Mitchell but
this is for six months you can't be out
of school for that long
yes I can no you can't not during the
school year and as we all know there's
no schools in Australia so his parents
leave him with his Uncle Louie in
Cincinnati Cincinnati oh there's no
waves there he meets up with his uncle
and aunt who believe he's a righteous
dude and he also meets up with his
cousin Wiley played by Seth what the
hell who brought the emo girl is it
going
nice to meet you like
good god it's like they put John Lennon
carrot top and mrs. incredible into some
sort of horrific genetic mutation even
in the 90s that hairdo wouldn't fly and
we invented this
so Wiley shows him around the school
he'll be going to but of course the
surfer dude has a hard time fitting yet
Wiley
cool walking in Cincinnati is a lot
different than walking in California he
doesn't seem to fit into his new class
either but to be fair when you expect
when the leader of the nasties is in the
classroom Oh
so the teacher allows everybody to come
up front and introduce themselves to the
class
Molly Ryan's money I have a 3.8 GPA my
name is snake I ain't got no hobbies
lets you call collecting knives and
putting tattoos across the foreheads of
guys I don't like hobbies the gym ball
gonna be sports announcer I refuse to
stop wait a minute who is that one guy
why'd you just come to him for a second
didn't have anything to say so random
Augusto Rafael de la paura uh everyone
just calls me Auggie though okay thank
you Rosenblatt that's fine I don't get
it what's funny about that you cut to a
guy with the braces nose who doesn't
talk what's the joke you know fine I can
cut to that moron to what
don't you let go
you
see that wasn't hard
now give me movie with Seth Green eject
lack to fill well I don't have any
stories don't know what I want to be
when I grow don't care just as long as
they live near the beach and don't have
to wear tie then I'll be stuck I gotta
be smooth cool confident I have a few
things to say could I have something
please anyone here believe it's a la
laid-back horse
the fruity to shoot uh so is the teacher
just asleep right now it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of control in this
class did other schools do this during
student introductions I tell you know
why my friends it's a consciousness
writer yes yes very nice Mitchell Auggie
you maple Julius Alton white well gospel
very nice manners whoa the oh honey airs
are wound a little too tight on that one
hey dude what'd you say no seriously
what did you say none of us could
understand what that meant I just said
uh what a fine public speaker Augie was
pretty boy surfer shucks sorry that is
our word but then Jack this guy not that
guy gets up and makes his own intro why
don't you try hockey we got a game today
against the preps
all righty bits of crap boy we've never
beaten the preps we're gonna do it today
we're gonna kick the preps butt Wow
this class has three school spirit even
though apparently they're back straight
losers
whoa whoa wait a minute okay if anyone's
gonna be made fun of in this classroom
it's not the surfer dude it is this kid
I mean look at him how do they just
avoid him it's like someone took silly
putty put it on picture Luke Perry and
just latched it out I mean come on this
kid is mocked but this guy gets a free
pass but fuck's wrong with this school
but another problem pops up as well Pico
and Freddie just got caught putting a
class mrs. crow it's coffee better count
them out for the game that's alright
well uh we'll get somebody so they need
two more players praising the cut cut
here and Wiley yeah you're playing
hockey today ah great
I guess why me because lord knows
there's no other students in the entire
freakin school they could pick I'm gonna
keep losing but so what why we gets his
ass kicked
like Wiley mitchell starts to hit it off
with the ladies you know it's funny you
get so busy fighting over waves that you
never get a chance to enjoy the ocean
life's too short
so if you're not into fighting what are
you into I like the smell of the ocean
the purple sunsets and surfing in the
rain you're a poet now I just know what
I like I know I heard it too
here's Bruce Campbell killing something
to offset it swallow this but why he
gets knocked out of the game
big shot so they need somebody else to
take his place hey how about that you
just illegally went out on the ice all
right you're up surfer once again tell
me this doesn't remind you of a certain
commercial all right you're up surfer
but first let's start with a complete
breakfast including Mike Ross this place
however this does have a little bit of a
different end he scores for the wrong
team oh never mind you blow that's the
rock ball I'm sorry sorry man you cost
us again what do you expect you pick
Claire Danes from my so-called life and
half the boyfriends from full house what
did you think was gonna happen so
because of his fuckup all the kids in
school keep playing pranks on it somehow
knowing exactly where he's gonna go at
every single moment of the day
riff-raff street rat I don't buy that if
only they'd look closer I need traffic
smog keyways I didn't breed oh for God's
sake I need the ocean I can't take it
anymore man yeah
if high school has taught us anything
it's that it is very very difficult to
be a beautiful white athletic male but
it turns out Nicky still has the hots
for him and she shows him around one of
the gardens that Cincinnati has to offer
oh this one's a gimme you got it right
here
Mitchell Mitchell
well maybe gotcha screw girls I got
rollerblades
so it says genetically perfected T
continued to smile nikki finds she just
has to ask him out on a date I was
supposed to go out on the town with
Wiley Friday night well bring him along
I don't know if he can find a day in
town I could bring a friend cool just
make sure her hair isn't as pretty as
his he gets kind of jealous so Friday is
a long ways away what's he gonna do
until then oh just stuff
get your skis shined up grab a sticker
do some fruit
the taste is gonna move yeah take a snip
pull it out the taste is gonna move when
you're popping your my juicy fruit it's
gonna move yeah it just the song it gets
right to your kills it fruit the taste
the taste the taste is gone
so after that Australian scene we cut to
Mitchell telling Wylie about our
headband really you're wearing a
headband I got a date with her Friday
night we're supposed to go out Friday
night okay leave your balls at the front
desk you are a lady I mean seriously
we're just one second away from having
that girly montage you know when they
try on different clothes and they laugh
at one another should my shirt so sexy
okay hand them over
give me your testicles no honestly you
don't deserve you deserve hey you wanted
them over I'll try to by force
I mean good lord doesn't this movie have
any idea what boys do oh and hey for
anyone who thinks that this could be
considered a typical teenage boy thing
all the guys say is watch it - this
music
but before Mitchell goes on his date he
must indulge in his Zen surf his surf if
you will Point Break right spitting like
a washing machine an awesome ride even
more awesome because he's in Cincinnati
yes you know I really didn't think a
surf fetish could exist but now I'm
convinced it does and his kids got it
bad I mean this is sick this is actually
kind of sick if surfing was a girl she
would have had a restraining order out
against him I'm serious this is kind of
fucked up I mean what do you think is
porn looks like hey so while while he
starts to strike out on his date Nicki
and Mitchell seem to be hitting it off
pretty good
so you could have lunch with any food
people in the entire world would it be
well I'd have to say Tom Curren greatest
server a lot and maybe Gandhi the
world's greatest surfer and Gandhi what
a combination
I choose the world's greatest surfer to
show that I'm athletic and Gandhi to
show that I've deep neck string dude
so the girls go to the bathroom to
discuss their dates I mean he came two
inches from slamming into a gas truck it
was like something out of red asphalt
he'll grow onions right not in this
lifetime no now we know why she turned
into a lesbian in the Brady Bunch movie
my dad shot it was weird wait a minute
what did he say
- yeah it was weird dude what the hell
was that story about no seriously can we
just skip this bullshit and hear what
story ends with my dad shot er tell me
you don't hear that story instead I mean
really tell me but unfortunately this
story continues as we see one of the
preps comes in and starts moving in on
his girl whoa looks like Nikki's got
herself a new little friend sort of a
private thing we got going here hey what
do you say we get together some other
time and go bowling or something but it
seems Jack of all people comes in to
save the day yeah why would you this has
got nothing to do with you stay away
from my sister
that's right Jack and Nikki are siblings
funny she never brought that up of
course Jack doesn't approve of Mitchell
dating her but Mitchell once again tries
to find the peaceful route hey what do
you say we all sit down talk about this
over basket of fries or something does
he always have a cowardly retort on
standby hey man what do you say we pick
roses and skip I'm taking Nikki home
there's nothing you can do about it well
I hate to ruin your fun but I'm not
gonna fight you Jack I'm not you afraid
of me
you st. giving me a tough look calling
me a few names putting sand in my
lockers gonna make me want to fight you
well you got another thing coming man
I'm out of here in three months three
months you think I'm gonna waste my time
on you or anyone else you ain't worth it
brah no one hears no wow I think that is
the proudest puss out speech I've ever
heard in my life I mean he fucking
flaunts it
he doesn't care who knows he's a
shivering pansy he'd expose and
everybody I mean are there other tough
ways of saying you're a complete and
total coward think you're all tough and
scary good let me tell you I just crap
my pant
right now they are filled with doodoo
and I am horrified horrified - this is
done I am gonna go home and cry like a
little girl oh yeah that's gonna be me
that that's gonna be me that's how scary
you are bitch but it turns out Nikki
doesn't like the fact that he's an utter
tool and decides to leave him behind
Nikki
so everybody abandons Mitchell even
Wiley which causes him to stay up all
night trying to figure out what he did
wrong we she get over it you know what
why don't you just go out with the way
yeah
it's obvious that's the only thing to
understands you and it doesn't have lips
to call you an absolute pussy wake up
man wake up well I had this dream there
there was this wave the one you ain't
getting another chance solar eclipse
wave until I see this this mondo shark
may just look like a guppy man and his
name was Pepe Pepe did I woke up you
wrote me a Tony allows each dream are
you kidding everything we need to know
is in our dreams man their windows to
enlightenment my god who is this kid why
was he destroy years of strong ethical
teachings with his absolute douchiness
well it's obvious that that jack is the
shark and Nicki's away what does it mean
you're gonna fight jack and have Gandhi
roll over in his grave I don't think so
why you gotta be so visual protege F
don't you forget besides you don't have
to fight the shark to fight for the wave
there's got to be some way I can
approach this I could complete until the
wuss so Mitchell sees that Jack and
friends are fighting for props at roller
hockey and he asks if he can join it
Jeff won't you just let the moron play
before if you let him play at least we
can watch him get a butt kick yeah you
guys got room for one more
Travis you're off do what is with these
idiots and letting other idiots play on
their team
did they not learn their lesson the
first time the anti Tony the Tiger
incident hello
but of course he starts to do well and
even impresses his girlfriend again
thank God being impressed by sports and
physical aggression doesn't make people
incredibly shallow or else she would be
a total bitch no that is not the code of
the pussy why didn't you do anything
Mitchell
Gandhi's rolling over in his grave
waiting a completely confused whatever
message you were trying to get across
movie you're right there are some things
worth fighting so as you see kids it's
not about physical violence it's just
about hurting somebody somehow that's
what really counts in life
so that all the reindeer loved him but
it turns out there's one other little
problem the movies just a little over an
hour dogs
how the hell are we gonna fill up the
rest of the time I've been challenged by
the preps to a little skating race we're
gonna settle this thing once and for all
we thought maybe you don't want to come
in just get in our team where's the race
Devil's Backbone Wow it's only the most
dangerous Hill in the whole town tannoy
business because we're tired of being
put down treated like lowlife trash
losers and we're somebody this is our
chance to prove it we can only do it as
a team we gotta show them that picking
up people because they're different
isn't right will you help us person we
recently picked on because he was
different
of course he says yes and the most
extreme raise from the most extreme
rivalry finally takes place
tensions are gonna have the day
the Jets are gonna have their ways and I
so the race is on and at first it's
actually not a bad race there's
surprisingly some good skating in and
even manages to be a little intense
so they race downhill and they race
downhill and they raise downhill okay at
first this was kind of exciting but
after 15 minutes of this it starts to
get a little old it's basically just the
rollerblade version of the Padres from
episode 1 first minutes kind of fun
second minutes a little annoying thir
minute is just grading and fourth minute
we got 12 more minutes on this shit God
by the way I think The Devil's Backbone
has scoliosis because it fucking goes
everywhere what is the garage part of
The Devil's Backbone is the stairway
part of The Devil's Backbone even your
GPS will give up at this point
ah no that doesn't have unless your
wheels are encased in flubber you just
jumped the shark oh I'm sorry
I need peppy
but Mitchell gets lost and can't find
his way back to the track this looks
like a job for cheating
sorry sorry it's just I'll never get
tired of that sound
so of course Mitchell wins the day and
everything turns out great we hope you
enjoyed this extremely long race and we
apologize for the rest of the movie that
had to come with
Nike just just don't do what this idiot
does and that was airborne the epitome
of nineties blandness this is one of
those films that should be placed in a
time capsule I'm not saying it totally
sums up the 90s but it sums of how the
media saw the 90s and is pretty much
every 90s cliche that existed at the
time in that sense it's sort of a wonder
apart from that sometimes Jack Black and
the other supporting cast can be funny
but the main characters a jackass the
writing is forgettable and the main
message is really confusing fight for
your rights and screw whatever Gandhi
said I don't know but if you're looking
for good generic stupidity from the
decade where these guys were popular
this would probably be your best bet
take it for what it's worth not a
nostalgia critic guy remember two years
you're a poet now I just know what I
like